Hello Everybody!
My name is Markiplier~
and welcome to Terror Lab
now this started off very strange
I sometimes explore the deepest reaches of the internet
to find... bizarre and interesting games
press enter to reset or r-...
[eerie silence]
Okay
Cool what did that do?
I have no idea
L-Flash bang ready
*flash bang*
Good God Man!
what did I do?!
that didn't do anything- I can't see!
OH Okay
well this is Dark and Spooky
Soooo
Anyway!
like I said-
*flash bang*
Again! That does not help anybody
it just blinds me
I'm flash banging myself
time to recover memory?
I don't-
AHH!! What The F*ck?!
HI!
Welcome To The Party Bro!
You're late where's the chicks, man?
Am I dead?
Or are you dead?
[jazzy game show music plays]
You know what?
I have not a goddamned idea what the hell just happened.
This game
is bizarre.
I cannot see a thing.
I cant seem to do-
OH I Have A Flashlight!
I thought that just because I had a flash bang
meant that I wouldn't ever have a flashlight.
okay so
let try to
meander without dying-
HEY! Whoa-ho-ho hey!
How's it going there?
Oh dude! Come on man!
[large bang and sounds of groaning]
Hi...
How are you doing?
well...
It's going to be one of 'Those Games'
I'm gonna call you Chad
because you're just as douchey as a Chad would be.
Not Offending Anybody-
God Dammit!
stop that!
That's Not Horror Music!
Stop It!
So it said something about a- muh...
said something about a radar?
I dunno-
I wasn't exactly
LEEE!
Re-LEE
Rehlgth!
I wasn't exactly reading the description
or the instructions
or anything that I was supposed to be doing
because I was too
flabbergasted
which is the only word that I can use in this situation
I was too flabbergasted
with what the hell was happening to me!
anyway
I was being subjected to senses that I've never
experienced before in my life
I can smell the rust on the walls!
it's just bad times all around
but anyway
lets try not to die...
Again...
To CHAAAD!!!
[bang and groaning sounds]
God Dammit Chad!
Why you gotta be such a prick Chad?!
god dammit Bro...
you're-you're
harshing my Buuuuzz~
Chad-
Stop It With The Music!
God Dammit!
CHAD!
You *sshole Chad!
...
alright Chad
you and me need to have a talk about the dynamics
oh yeah I have a flash bang!
should I use a flash bang when he comes a
running up to me?
Probably!
because Chad wants to party all day long
We Have An Exam In 24 Hours Chaaaad!
CHAD!!!
Did that get'cha Chad?
Did that wake you up?
oh god I cant see...
Oh He's Still There!
ohgchsh-!
I-I don't know why I expected Chad to just
Disappear on me!
like of course he was gonna come a-running
around the corner
but what am I?-
what am I supposed to do?
Am I just supposed to play keep away from Chaaad?
is he getting a little Frisky with me?
probably...
ChaAAAad
oh
ChaaAAAAAAAAAAAad~
*grunt*
HUARHG!
Chad you hear me grunting off in the distance?
that would normally get you running my way
if ya know what I mean~
I guess I gotta keep up the generator
which was back in the other room
but I don't know where Chad went...
Chad!
come on man! I didn't mean it!
I mean just because you're the worst frat Bro that I've
ever been a part of...
And I'm-ugh- I'm not saying that I'm a part of you!
And we're not!-
We're not like two halves of the whole whole!
and I don't wanna talk about 'wholes' when I'm...
around you Chad... but-
*ka-chick*
you know- tho-
it was just an experimental time in collage Chaaad!
I mean-
I- I- I- I've moved on!
Chad No!
Chad go away!
I feel like this game could easily replace the character
with Shrek
and put this-
ech!
and make this a-
a really Really hilarious Shrek simulator
just saying
it's entirely possible
I guess I gotta wait until the memory recovers-
But That's Gonna Take For Fricking Forever!
why am I gonna do that?
I'm gonna jump out this window
Chaaaad!
is that what you want
Chaaaaad?!
come on Chad!
show your true feelings!
we used to be closer than this Chaaad!
What happened to us Chaaad?!
what happened to the emotional connection that we
had on a deeper BRO Level Chad?!
we were just having a BROmance and you-
you made it all weird Chaaaad!
yeah you just wanted it to be physical Chaaad!
OH F*ck you...
what about the Antar-
Don't Remind Me Of Our Antarctic Cruise Chaaad!
Just Because We Were On A Cruise Together Doesn't
Mean That We're Meant To Be Together
Chaaad!
God Dammit Chad!
You Make Me Feel Things That I Don't Wanna Feel!
you make me think about times that I don't
wanna think about anymore!
All Of Our BRO Moments!
Our BROments!
It Was Good You Know?!
It Was BRude!
Gu-That's BRO Word For Good!
We Hade A Great Time!
BROing Out In The Bur-wu
BRoods!
That's Woods In BRO Speak!
Huntin'
BRO Deer!
.......
*sniff*
Whatever Cha-
GAH! F*ck You Chad!!!
Always Sneaking Up Behind Me Chad!
Stop Reminding To Me Of The time We Went Dancing
Chaaad!
Aw Shut Up Chad!
I Know That's Our Song Chad But You Gotta Let It Go!
Chaaad!
*Sniff*
It was so long ago...
I've moved on...
Cha-hahad!
press Enter to stop Audio System?
I donno what that means!
oh... Hey chad!
god you're so silent when you're creeping up to me
Chad!
remember when you used to talk to me?!
you know?
we used to talk through our problems
Chaaad!
just cause I dumped you-
I BRO dumped you
doesn't mean that you gotta be all
cramping me style BRO!
m-my- my
BRO Style~
My BRyle!
Yeah I Call It BRyle!
Shut Up!
we used to have good times Chad...
we used to have good times
back in our early party days
And I Know...
I Know Stacy Got In Between Both Of Us!
Literally And Figuratively!
but you gotta let shome sthings go!
yea- Shome sthings!
sorry I go back into my
*wheeze*
collage Lisp-peh when I think of you
Bing!
oh sorry Chad I just thought you were around the corner
didn't know you were gonna be-shsnush-
not sneaking up on me
like you usually do
Chaaad!
he was alw -
You Were Always A Rouge
Chaaad!
A BROge!
A BRO Rouge!
You Know What It Is!
AHH! F*ck!
God Dammit Chaaad!!!
huagh...
I've had enough or your bullsh*t Chad...
Chad you have a nice *ss but stop showing it to me
you're not tempting me at all...
Anything
Shut!
Get A Ph-!
What Is With The Monkey?!
ahh...
Our Bro Monkey!
Our BRonkey!
Chad you remember back in collage
when we used to play spank the BRonkey?
HaBuph!
it went a lot like that
*whimper*
Just Over In A Flash!
A BRO Flash!
A BRash!
Shut Up!
Shut Up Chad!
Oh there you are, you cant even move Chaaad!
You cant even do Nothing!
Chaaad!
What Are You Gonna Do Chaaad!?
Yer Frozen Like A Statue!
A BRO Statue!
A BRachu!
And That's Not A Pokémon!
BROkémon!
shut up I'm broken...
I'm BROken inside~
[Laughter]
I don't see anyway to win
Chaaad...
I don't see anyway to win what we have back...
what we had back!
I Don't See Anything
Chad!
I don't see anything but the sadness you've left
in my heart!
My BRO Heart!
MY BRART!!!
don't make fun of me Chad...
Don't Mock Me!
you know that I'm sensitive...
You Know Where I'm Sensitive!
hey Chad
Boink!
neah
that's the last time I'll flash you!
...........
willingly!
Oh! Whoa!
hey Chad!
you got a little closer than I thought!
just like back in college!
Why Can't I Quit You!?
Why Can't I Quit You Cha!?-
I thought this was a door
I thought I was making A dramatic entrance ther-
Exit there
HABoo!
sorry Chad
had to do it
had to do it Chad
oh! Agre-
Agressivity?!
oh! We're Going To Talk About Aggressiveness Now!
Chaaad!
Oh We're Gonna Trock About Your
BROgressiveness!
Huh! What Don't You Try To Be More
BRO Progresive!
BROgresive!
And Learn What
Being Men Is Really About?!
Which Is Getting In Touch With Your
BRO Feelings!
Your BReelings!
.....
Chad!
where you coming from Chad?
oh hi Chaad!
Bleuh...
you know...
I can't keep this up Chad...
you know-
OH- hey! Hi Chad!
No! Chad I Thought My Flashing Was Enough!
stop reminding me about the dancing times we had
Chad!
*sniff*
I cant bear-
Shut Up Chad!
you stupid monkey!
you BRonkey!
God Damn The BRonkey!
Stop Spanking My BRonkey!
okay
So Anyway!
I-*wheeze*
I'm done with here
I think I've
I think I've revealed a lot of very disturbing
personality flaws about
myself!
and my uh-
deep seated issues with Chaaad
So
I'm gonna end this here before it even gets started so
Thank You Everybody So Much For Watching!
god dammit...
I have no idea what just happened
but this is a game
and if you wanna play this game
I'll put a link down in the description down below
I don't even remember where I got it
I just saw that it was on my list-
Chad No!
*flash bang*
so that you again everybody so much for watching!
and as always!
I will see you~
and Chad
in the next video!
Bye Chad!
Buh Bye!
oh F*ck...
What's that? I got a bag of bah BUH!?
aH UH UAAHHH NO
Surprised me so much
Jeez get out of my life...